this is absolutely hilarious remember
that obvious scam that was a GoFundMe
campaign claiming to be raising money to
build Donald Trump's wall on the
us-mexico border and 20 million dollars
were actually donated this is the wall
by the way that was definitely going to
be paid for by Mexico that we've not
heard a word about from Donald Trump for
about three months now back in December
a guy named Brian Cole fij started a
GoFundMe campaign saying the government
won't do it if Trump won't do it if
Democrats will get in the way we can do
it ourselves let's raise the money we're
gonna try to raise a billion dollars
which of course even if they did would
have only paid for like a tiny sliver of
wall coal Fitch said that every penny
would be refunded if they didn't get the
billion dollars well they didn't get the
billion dollars they raised twenty
million dollars of people's money which
is insane and he claims he's not giving
the money back because he is going to
start building parts of the wall on
private land and that's why he's not
refunding people's money and supposedly
they were gonna break ground in April
we're now in May nothing has actually
been done the updates to the GoFundMe
page have slowed down to being almost
non-existent and now like only now these
absolutely
imbecilic Trump supporters and wall
builders are starting to sit to think
starting to suggest that maybe they were
scammed and they threw their money away
at something absolutely and totally
ridiculous and of course there are some
donors who are starting to say
authorities should really step in and
take care of this they should help us
get our money back from this scam which
doesn't really sound like small
government to me and I'm not one of
these ultra libertarian buyer beware
types I do believe in government
regulation I do believe in government
oversight and and all of that you know
that if you've been watching this show
for a while but GoFundMe has disclaimers
about how the donor must research what
they're donating to why exactly should
the government step in here and refund
people's money but there's an even
bigger truth here which is undeniable
which is that if you voted for Donald
Trump you got scammed right I mean the
entire campaign
was a scam by a professional scammer
Trump University Trump steaks Trump's
real estate deals Trump's campaign
Trump's presidency it's all been a scam
if you got bamboozled into voting for
Trump it's not really that surprising
that you fell for this obvious and
stupid GoFundMe scam to build the wall
the universe of Trump is riddled with
it's almost exclusively bogus empty
promises so Trump aswer really the
perfect mark for Brian coalfish to raise
twenty million dollars off of them
supposedly to build the wall I will make
an offer today to every single person
who donated to this wall and thinks it
might be a scam send me a hundred bucks
and I'll investigate for you whether you
got scammed and I'll get you a report
about that very very soon give me a
break guys okay if you couldn't tell
that this was an obvious scam from the
beginning I don't think that you deserve
any of the money back and certainly it
should not be the government bailing you
out although I would be totally fine
with a civil suit against Brian Cole fij
if that's the way you want to approach
it let me know what you think should the
government step in here I think the
answer is no we have a voicemail number
that number is two one nine